[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und schön
guten Abend viel Fußball heute von Rudi
zerner schöne Tore dabei guten Abend und
wir schauen heute unter anderem auf die
lex an den Pipelines
wahrscheinlich Sabotage so erklärt sich
die EU die kaputten nordstream Pipelines
und droht mit Sanktionen noch gegen
unbekannt
wie nach Drehbuch kaum sind die
scheinreferenten in der Ostukraine
abgeschlossen bitten die pro-russischen
Separatisten dort um Anschluss an
Russland
und Weg der Zerstörung Hurricane hat
Kuba schwer getroffen und zieht weiter
Richtung Norden erste Ausläufe erreichen
gerade Florida
[Musik]
Europäische Union und NATO gehen davon
aus dass die Pipelines an den drei
Stellen absichtlich beschädigt wurden
Russland weist Vermutungen zurück hinter
einer Sabotage zu stecken und fordert
wegen der lex an den nordstream
Pipelines eine Sondersitzung des
UN-Sicherheitsrates das Gas tritt in der
Nähe der dänischen Insel Bornholm aus
ein Bericht von Isabel Schäfers immer
weiter strömt Gas aus den zerstörten
pipeline-abschnitten in die Ostsee die
lex sei nicht durch Seebeben sondern
durch Detonationen entstanden so die
Experten auch in Brüssel ist man sich
einig es handelte sich um eine
vorsätzliche Störung die EU kündigt
deshalb schriftlich eine gemeinsame
Reaktion an und droht mit Gegenmaßnahmen
die eu-kommissionspräsidentin schreibt
von der stärksten möglichen Antwort was
genau das heißt und gegen wen sich diese
Antwort eigentlich richten soll bleibt
offiziell ungesagt
wir sind selbstverständlich in Kontakt
mit den Mitgliedstaaten und unterstützen
jede Form der Aufklärung um Klarheit
darüber zu bekommen von wem diese
Sabotage ausging und natürlich
unternehmen wir Schritte um unsere
Energiesicherheit besser zu schützen
auch in Berlin spricht man von einem
beunruhigenden Ereignis die
Verantwortlichen müssten schnell
identifiziert werden unsere Marine wird
sich mit ihrer Expertise bei der
Aufklärung Einbringen der mutmaßliche
Sabotageakt an den ostseepipelines führt
uns erneut vor Augen dass wir auf
kritische Infrastruktur angewiesen sind
auch unter Wasser nur wenige sprechen
heute offen aus was viele für möglich
halten und Militärexperten für
wahrscheinlich das Russland involviert
ist
man könnte in Betracht ziehen dass es
Russland einen Vorteil bringt den
europäischen Energiemarkt noch weiter zu
destabilisieren und diesbezüglich
weitere Unsicherheit zu schaffen
Russland weist den Vorwurf als dumm und
absurd zurück das weiterhin austretende
Gas behindert laut dänischer Regierung
bisher die Untersuchung der lex eine
Inspektion sei erst in ein bis zwei
Wochen möglich
in der EU aber gerade auch in
Deutschland ist man also alarmiert
angesichts der möglichen Sabotage gegen
eine solch kritische Infrastruktur wie
die Pipelines wie geschützt sind solche
Leitungen Thomas Gonsior ist der Frage
nachgegangen
die Bilder sind schon mehr als 20 Jahre
alt sie zeigen aber etwas von aktueller
Bedeutung diese Gasleitung europreib
damals verlegt soll Deutschland im
Winter mit Energie versorgen zwei von
ihnen je gut 600 km bringen Gas von
Norwegen durch die Nordsee zu uns ebenso
die Verbindung nordpype wichtig weil
nordstream 1 und 2 in der Ostsee nicht
für Lieferungen in Frage kommen was
schon vor den Lex klar war die Frage nun
sind die Pipelines sicher schützt sie
jemand von einer abstrakten
Gefährdungslage spricht das
Innenministerium ihre Chefin sagt die
Bundespolizei ist mit ihren Schiffen 24
Stunden am Tag und sieben Tage in der
Woche auf Nord- und Ostsee unterwegs
sprich sie sollen Schutz geben aber
reicht das zu viel Pipeline für zu
wenige Grenzschützer auch international
sagen Experten diese Partners lassen
sich nicht lückenlos kontrollieren
sind ja sehr sehr lange strenge die über
viele hundert Kilometer zum Beispiel in
der Ostsee laufen zweifelhaft auch ob
die Behörden über genug Mittel verfügen
etwa unter Wasser Drohnen abzufangen
eine solche britische dient der
Minenräumung denkbar grundsätzlich aber
ein Einsatz zur Sabotage Fazit die
Sicherheitslage ist sehr schlecht das
kann man nur in aller Klarheit so sagen
Deutschland ist ein hoch vulnerables
Land und Deutschland hat wie in fast
allen Bereichen die seine Sicherheit
betreffen auch hier in den vergangenen
30 Jahren nahezu alles verschlafen und
nun Norwegens premier störe verspricht
heute einen stärkeren Fokus auf Luft und
See er sieht keine konkrete Gefahr für
Energieanlagen wie gesagt es sind auch
jene für Deutschlands Wärme im Winter
wie angreifbar wären auch Strom und
Internetleitung in Nord- und Ostsee
darum geht es um 19 Uhr bei ZDF heute
live in der Mediathek und auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen die Gas legst und
die Suche nach den Tätern und ihren
Gründen lesen Sie mehr dazu auf ZDF
heute und in der App
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
hat den Mitgliedstaaten ein neues achtes
Sanktionspaket gegen Russland
vorgeschlagen es soll unter anderem
einen preisdeckel für russisches Öl
möglich machen wir akzeptieren keine
scheinabstimmungen oder jegliche
annektionen in der Ukraine sagte von der
Leyen auch die USA und Kanzler Scholz
verurteilten die sogenannten
Abstimmungen in den von Russland
besetzten Gebieten Nina Niebergall
es scheint wie ein gut einstudiertes
Theaterstück schon in der Nacht freuen
sich diese paratistenführer über
angeblich überwältigend klare Ergebnisse
heute wendet sich unter anderem der Chef
der selbsternannten Volksrepublik Lohans
offiziell an russlands Präsident Putin
die Bevölkerung unserer Republik hat
dieser Entscheidung in dem Referendum
zugestimmt ich bitte Sie die
Zugehörigkeit der Volksrepublik johannsk
als Teil der Russischen Föderation in
Erwägung zu ziehen
die Ergebnisse zu hoch unglaubwürdig zu
sein aus den vier Regionen werden
Zustimmungsraten von bis zu 99%
vermeldet
russland will die Annexion bald
offiziell machen nächste Woche soll in
der Duma über einen entsprechendes
Gesetz abgestimmt werden auf den Straßen
Moskau gibt es dafür nicht von jedem
Beifall
[Musik]
freue mich wenn es so für die Menschen
in der luhanska und der donetzka
Volksrepublik besser ist
in Kriegszeiten irgendwelche Referenten
abzuhalten das ist nicht sehr gut denke
ich es muss jetzt Frieden herrschen dann
können Entscheidungen getroffen werden
das ist alles schlecht dieser Krieg das
ist schlecht ich möchte nicht darüber
sprechen
vielen Russen reicht es das wird in
diesen Tagen immer deutlicher um der
time mobil machen zu entgehen verlassen
sie fluchtartig das Land etwa über die
georgische Grenze laut Medienberichten
sind in den vergangenen Tagen insgesamt
über 200.000 Menschen ausgereist
nach Berlin die Staatsanwaltschaft hat
die Bundesgeschäftsstelle der AFD
durchsucht es geht um frühere
Rechenschaftsberichte und Parteispenden
es bestehe der Anfangsverdacht dass
gegen das Parteiengesetz verstoßen wurde
unter Anfangsverdacht der Untreue die
Ermittlungen richten sich gegen den
ehemaligen Vorsitzenden Meuthen und den
früheren Schatzmeister Vormann
der Verfassungsschutz waren vor einer
Zuspitzung bundesweiter Proteste gegen
die hohen Energiepreise und die deutsche
russland-politik der Ton bei solchen
Veranstaltungen werden aggressiver so
heute Verfassungsschutzpräsident halten
waren gerade in Ostdeutschland nimmt die
Zustimmung zum demokratischen System
weiter ab so ein Bericht des
ostbeauftragten der Bundesregierung
Carsten Schneider mehr dazu von Diana
zimmermann
Proteste gegen die hohen Energiepreise
bislang nur im Osten Deutschland
Inflation und Gaspreise treffen hier auf
immer noch geringere Einkommen und
weniger Vertrauen in die Politik als im
Westen der Beauftragte der Regierung für
Ostdeutschland zeigt Verständnis meine
Bitte ist nur bei denen die dort gehen
dass sie sensibel sind wem sie
hinterherlaufen und da welche parolene
Fahnen auch aber ich nehme das als auch
als Ventil nach war viele haben auch
einfach wirklich Existenz Angst der
jüngste Bericht zur Lage in
Ostdeutschland spricht von einer
positiven Wirtschaftsentwicklung und
Milliarden Investitionen etwa in
Magdeburg dennoch liegen die
durchschnittlichen Bruttogehälter und
Vermögen in allen ostdeutschen Ländern
weiter unter denen des Westens und je
kleiner die Reserven desto größer die
Ungeduld
eine Umfrage unter 4.000 Bürgern zeigt
das insgesamt nur noch 42 Prozent der
Deutschen zufrieden sind mit der
politischen Situation im Land im Westen
ist der Wert von 54 auf 44 Prozent
gesunken im Osten von 40 auf nur noch 31
Prozent
für die starke Politikverdrossenheit hat
der Innenminister Thüringens auch 32
Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung vor
allem eine Erklärung die Erfahrung aus
der Wendezeit das plötzlich alles in
Frage gestellt war das plötzlich alles
was man sich aufgebaut hat wieder weg
ist und die Sorge haben halt viele
Menschen wenn sie jetzt sehen dass diese
Krisen also einmal die Pandemie und
jetzt der Krieg sich aneinanderreihen
und immer stärker werden
auch die flüchtlings- und Europapolitik
den Stand der Demokratie und der
Meinungsfreiheit sehen die Ostdeutschen
deutlich kritischer als die
Westdeutschen vereint wissen sich alle
in der sicheren Erwartung dass dieser
Winter ein ungewöhnlich harter wird
das Wohngeld verdoppeln die Zahl der
Berechtigten verdreifachen die
Bundesregierung hat die Reform des
Wohngeldes beschlossen um
einkommensschwache Haushalte zu
entlasten der Gesetzentwurf von
bauministerin Gallwitz sieht einen
Anstieg der staatlichen Hilfe um
durchschnittlich 190 Euro im Monat vor
außerdem sollen zu den 600.000
wohngeldberechtigten Haushalten und 1,4
Millionen dazukommen der Reform soll im
kommenden Jahren Kraft treten muss aber
noch Bundestag und Bundesrat passieren
wie das finanziert wird ist aber noch
ein Streitpunkt zwischen Bund und
Ländern heute gab es dazu ein
Krisengespräch der
ministerpräsidentinnen und Präsidenten
erstmal ohne Kanzler Scholz der
corona-bedingt ausfällt ich hoffe über
die Finanzierung gibt es außerdem bei
einer Nachfolgeregelung für das
neuroticket und dem Mehrbedarf der
Krankenhäuser wegen steigender Energie-
und gerade hat die Pressekonferenz
angefangen Theo Koll beobachtet das für
uns was können Sie uns denn schon sagen
worauf haben sich die Länder geeinigt
ich kann noch nicht sagen worauf sie
sich geeinigt haben der Vorsitzende der
MPK hat nur gerade gesagt man habe sich
geeinigt hat vor einer Minute angefangen
das überraschende war dass man sich aber
so lange heute nicht einigen konnte denn
reingegangen war man eigentlich mit
einer einstimmigen Einigung der
Länderfinanzminister bei der es vor
allem darum ging und gehen sollte wie
wollen die Länder vom jüngsten
Entlastungspaket des Bundes wiederum
selbst finanziell entlastet werden und
da ging es beispielsweise um den
erweiterten Kreis von
wohngeld-empfängern das sollte künftig
der Bund komplett übernehmen es ging um
höhere Krankenhauskosten oder die Kosten
für steigende Flüchtlingszahlen da wird
es interessant sein was jetzt im
Beschluss steht die Kritik der Länder
war dass der Bund ein Entlastungspaket
beschließt die Länder aber einen Teil
der Rechnung bezahlen sollen der große
Streitpunkt heute war dann
offensichtlich die Frage ob die Länder
die Aufhebung der Schuldenbremse fordern
die sogenannten a-länder also die die
geführten wollten das die
unionsgeführten überwiegend nicht
darüber hat man so heißt es heute lange
gestritten jetzt gibt es nur eine Art
Protokollerklärung einzelner Länder und
alles andere soll dann kommende Woche
mit dem Kanzler entschieden werden
Dankeschön Theo call
fehlende Stimmzettel stundenlange
Wartezeiten Wahllokale die noch nach 18
Uhr geöffnet waren bei den Wahlen vor
einem Jahr unter anderem des Berliner
Abgeordnetenhauses lief sehr viel schief
der Berliner Verfassungsgerichtshof hält
daher nach einer vorläufigen
Einschätzung eine komplette Wiederholung
der Wahlen für erforderlich über den
Verhandlungsauftakt Roman Lesko war
ungewöhnlich schon der Orte mündlichen
Verhandlung erstmals hat Berlins
Verfassungsgericht außerhalb des eigenen
Hauses getagt wegen der vielen
Beteiligten ging es in einen Uni Hörsaal
nicht weniger spektakulär die vorläufige
Einschätzung des Gerichts die Berlinwahl
könnte möglicherweise ungültig gewesen
sein das heißt das neue Wahlen
durchzuführen sind weil die Fehler die
geschehen sind zu umfassend und zu
zahlreich gewesen sein es war eine
Abstimmung mit gravierenden Pannen
stundenlanges Schlange stehen
wahlberechtigte die nicht abstimmen
konnten falsche Stimmzettel das Gericht
geht davon aus dass nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs dokumentiert sei die Berliner
Opposition sieht für das Chaos die
rot-grün-rote Koalition voll
verantwortlich
Franziska giffer ist mit dem heutigen
Tag gefühlt eine regierender auf Abrufe
aber ich erwarte dass sie zumindest
funktionierende Neuwahlen noch
sicherstellen wird es ist natürlich eine
unglaubliche ja Klatsche kann man sagen
für den Berliner Senat unter SPD-Führung
die für Wahlen zuständige
Innenverwaltung zeigt sich überrascht
von der Einschätzung Behörde und Gericht
würden die Pannen unterschiedlich
bewerten wir haben eigentlich
festgestellt dass in neun von zehn
Wahllokalen eigentlich es keine
Vorkommnisse gab die eine
mandatsrelevanz haben und hier habe ich
den Eindruck dass das der
Verfassungsgerichtshof das nicht
berücksichtigt drei Monate bleiben dem
Gericht nach der Verhandlung um
endgültig zu urteilen bis dahin können
die Richter ihre Meinung noch ändern
bleibt es dabei wird in Berlin
spätestens nach weiteren 90 Tagen neu
gewählt
die Deutsche Bahn erhöht die Preise im
Fernverkehr ab Mitte Dezember werden
Fahrten in IC und ICE um
durchschnittlich 4,9% teurer um gleich
viel steigen dann auch die Preise der
Bahncards grund sei die hohe Inflation
teilte das Unternehmen mit für den
Regionalverkehr war bereits Anfang
September einer Erhöhung um 4%
angekündigt worden
die Deutsche Bischofskonferenz stellt
sich im Kampf gegen sexualisierte Gewalt
in der katholischen Kirche neu auf neuer
missbrauchsbeauftragter wird der
Aachener Bischof Helmut dieser erfolgt
auf Bischof Stefan Ackermann bei der
Herbstvollversammlung sagte Bischof
dieser die Kirche könne an dem Skandal
um die sexualisierte Gewalt von Kindern
jugendlich und Erwachsenen kaputt gehen
Peter Theisen
es war schwerer sexueller Missbrauch den
Jens wendel in seiner Kindheit erleben
musste ich bin Messdiener gewesen und
wurde im Religionsunterricht von unserem
Religionslehrer der auch gleichzeitig
der Pfarrer in der Gemeinde Sorsum war
immer wieder missbraucht so wie wir es
auch bei vielen anderen getan hat obwohl
die Bischöfe über die pädophilen
Neigungen des Pfarrers Bescheid wussten
passierte nichts außer Versetzungen in
neue Gemeinden viele kritisieren auch
bei der Aufarbeitung der vielen Skandale
habe der bisherige
Missbrauchsbeauftragte Bischof Ackermann
nicht entschieden genug gehandelt
künftig sollen Opfer und Experten
stärker eingebunden werden der neue
Missbrauchsbeauftragte gelobt mehr
Engagement das ist eben nicht
Verzögerungen geben soll die nicht in
der Sache begründbar wären sondern die
aus irgendwelchen
sagen wir mal Lahmheiten oder
Verweigerungen kommen das dürfen wir
angesichts der der wirklich der des
Leides dieser Menschen um die es geht
nicht tun Jens Windel aber hat das
Vertrauen in die Aufklärungsarbeit der
Bischöfe längst verloren er fordert dass
der Staat sich in Zukunft darum kümmern
soll es muss der Staat machen weil die
katholische Kirche hat bewiesen dass sie
es nicht kann ein System bei dem die
Führungsriege so intensiv in den Skandal
verstrickt ist wie das in der
katholischen Kirche der Fall ist kann
sich nicht selber aufklären beim besten
Willen nicht und wenn bei einigen dann
auch noch der gute Wille fehlt dann geht
schon mal gleich gar nicht für die neuen
Missbrauchsbeauftragten dürfte es extrem
schwierig werden das Vertrauen der Opfer
wiederzugewinnen
und jetzt noch Amerika womit Hurrikan
Ian in der Karibik einer der
gewaltigsten Stürme der letzten Jahre
tobt
aktuell nimmt der Wirbelsturm Kurs auf
den west-bundesstaat Florida und der ist
noch stärker geworden us-fach läuft
Leute stuften ihren heute auf die
zweithöchste Kategorie hoch zuvor hatte
der Hurrikan Kuba überquert und mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von 200
Stundenkilometern massive Schäden
angerichtet Claudia Bates berichtet
das Wellblechdach ist weggeflogen bei
Anna hullya Gomez steht alles unter
Wasser ihr Haus ist jetzt unbewohnbar
und fast alles darin ist kaputt
es ist ein Desaster so etwas wie diesen
Sturm habe ich noch nie erlebt
zwei Menschen starben unter den Trümmern
von Gebäuden Hurrikan Ian trifft Kuba in
einer ohnehin schwierigen Zeit
Wirtschaftskrise an kleinere
Stromausfälle hatten sich die Menschen
fast gewöhnt jetzt aber sind Millionen
ohne Strom
wir haben keine Ahnung was wir tun
sollen alles ist kaputt schau dir diesen
Zustand an
und während Kuba mit den Folgen kämpft
hat der Hurricane weiter an Kraft
gewonnen auf seinem Weg Richtung USA an
der Küste Floridas ist bereits so viel
Regen gefallen das Teile der Südspitze
unter Wasser stehen und kleine tornados
haben Bäume umgemäht Stromleitungen
beschädigt und stellen schon jetzt alles
auf den Kopf
das wird lebensgefährlich wenn Sie in
diesem Sturm sind riskieren Sie Ihre
Gesundheit ihre Sicherheit und ihr Leben
Millionen von Menschen müssen sich in
Sicherheit bringen zunächst aber wollen
sie ihre Häuser schützen und sich
eindecken mit dem Nötigsten lange
Schlangen in den Supermärkten Wasser
Babynahrung Toilettenpapier gibt es kaum
noch
ich hole einen Generator für den Fall
der Fälle ich brauche Sandsäcke und ein
paar Benzinkanister und tausende sind
unterwegs Richtung Norden Richtung
Sicherheit
kommen wir jetzt zum Fußball für die U21
Nationalmannschaft lief es ja wieder
nicht gut Rudi erneut verloren
Deutschlands Fußball Junioren haben zum
Auftakt der EM-Saison die zweite
Niederlage kassiert vier Tage nach dem
0:1 gegen Frankreich hat die Mannschaft
von Trainer Antonio di salvo im nächsten
Härtetest erneut das Nachsehen in
scheffelt verliert das DFB-Team mit 1 zu
Trainer Antonio di salvo hat noch was zu
tun seine DFB-Auswahl in den dunklen
Trikots geht in Sheffield zwar in der 35
Minute durch den Wolfsburger Felix de
Matcha in Führung doch das von Noah
Katterbach perfekt vorbereitete Tor
bringt kaum mehr Sicherheit noch vor der
Pause kommt vor der den Balogun für
England zum Ausgleich
die zweite Hälfte hat gerade begonnen da
erhöhen sie auf zwei zu eins Connor
Gallagher ohne Mühe
beim Drang zum Ausgleich machen die
Deutschen am Ende Fehler einer führt zum
Konter in der Nachspielzeit den koopamer
zur 3:1 Entscheidung nutzt im November
gibt es die nächsten Testspiele im
Hinblick auf die em-end-runde im Sommer
in Rumänien und Georgien
und als viertes und letztes Team hat
Deutschlands WM Gruppengegner Spanien
den Einzug ins Finalturnier der nations
League geschafft und zwar dank eines
Sieges beim bisherigen Tabellenführer
Portugal
ausgelassene spanische Freude nach Sieg
in Portugal der gegnerische Superstar
Ronaldo einfach nur frustriert auch in
der Nationalelf läuft es in dieser
Saison nicht rund für den einstigen
Torgaranten stattdessen trifft Spanien
als es in der Schlussphase endlich voll
auf Sieg spielt 88 Minute Williams auf
morata der 1:0 Siegtreffer zum Gruppen
gewinnen
denn Cristiano Ronaldo bleibt glücklos
und in gänzlich anderer Gemütsverfassung
als die Spanier
ein wunderbarer Sport so ein Sieg ist
einfach das beste Mittel gegen
Depression und jede Form von Traurigkeit
es stand im tatsächlich ins Gesicht
geschrieben
ja und das war der kurze wunderbare
sportblock
zu den Lottozahlen diese Zahlen wurden
heute gezogen die Gewinnzahlen lauten 4
12 13 33 44 49 die Superzahl ist die 6
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
mehr Sonne als in den letzten Tagen gibt
es morgen wo genau das erfahren Sie
gleich von Katja horneffer das heute
journal können Sie am 21.45 sehen mit
Christian Sievers auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend so abwechslungsreich unser
Wetter derzeit ist so wenig ändert sich
denn die Thies die Kreiseln einfach um
uns herum das bedeutet immer wieder
Regenschauer zwischendurch auch
Sonnenschein und noch wenig Wind das
wird sich zum Samstag dann ändern heute
Nacht noch nicht da fällt an den Küsten
von Nord und Ostsee und auch am
alpenbrand Regen in der Mitte aber
locker die Wolken auf da bildet sich
Nebel oder Dunst dann kann es auch kalt
werden dann sinken die Temperaturen auf
drei bis null Grad und am Boden reicht's
dann vielleicht sogar mal für Frost
unter den Regenwolken im Norden und im
Süden bleibt es bei acht bis vier Grad
milder und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen Mais so bei 11 bis 14
15 Grad 16 Grad werden es ja Niederrhein
nur neun Grad sind es am alten Rand und
morgen gibt es weitere Regenschauer vor
allen Dingen hier im Nordwesten und im
Süden da halten sich die Regenwolken
noch länger sonst werden sie aber häufig
mal die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen und
noch weht der Wind nicht besonders stark
aus südwestlichen Richtungen der Freitag
wird noch eine Spur freundlicher dann
gibt es noch Regenschauer hier im
Südosten und dann ändert sich das das
kommt ein Sturmtief die stürmische Böden
gibt es vor allen Dingen an der Nordsee
und in den Mittelgebirgen guten Abend